One of the exciting results,
if FHIR were widely adopted,
is that it could constitute
a universal health app platform.
Developers could then use that platform
to help solve some of the limitations
of current EHR systems we'll
discuss in lesson six.
They can also provide innovative tools
for patients, the topic of lesson seven.
In fact, such a platform already exists.
Harvard's Boston Children's Hospital
received federal funding
to develop a universal health
app platform called SMART.
The lasted version, SMART on FHIR,
is based on the new standard and
you can visit the app gallery
on their website using the link
provided in the instructor's notes to
see examples of SMART on FHIR apps.
These could be plugged directly into
any EHR that supports the platform.
I'll interview the chief
architect of the platform, Dr.
Josh Mandel at the end of lesson 5B.
HIMSS is the largest health
IT meeting in the world.
At the last two HIMSS meetings,
he demonstrated multiple EHRs
running the same third-party
apps using this approach.
Cerner and Epic, the two largest
enterprise healthcare software
companies, have announced FHIR support.
We believe it may not be long
before your most promising ideas
could plug into actual
electronic record systems.
You could then validate your team's
approach with real practicing
physicians, other clinical personnel,
and their patients.
Finally, it is also entirely possible
that FHIR will be further developed
to solve the analytic challenges,
we'll be discussing in
the lessons eight through ten